you
[Music]
thanks very much and thank you to you
all for not scheduling your flights out
too early my name is Ian fellows I'm a
CEO a fellow statistics for a small
boutique data science and statistics
consultancy in San Diego today I'm going
to be talking to you about a package
that I developed called IPC that was
really you know out of some born out of
some some problems and frustrations we
were having dealing with shiny apps when
there are long-running processes
involved where computationally intensive
now this is our right this is a
statistical computing language so we
shouldn't be too surprised when things
take you know a significant amount of
time doing bootstraps Markov chain Monte
Carlo or various complicated analytic
techniques and there are some design
considerations that you need to think
about when you're dealing with
long-running computationally intensive
tasks and you want to make those
available to a wider audience through a
shiny application the first and arguably
most important thing is don't block
everything right so if one user is doing
something computationally complex it
shouldn't block the entire server from
being able to do any computation so the
another user is use your interface all
of a sudden blocks up and they have no
idea why the second is that a single
user is so if you've got multiple things
going on in your application and one of
them is a computationally complex task
well all of the other interface elements
and outputs should not be blocked and
hang while the code is executing that
leads to a poor user experience and
third the user needs to have insight
into that computation you know if a user
doesn't know whether a computation is
going to take ten seconds or ten hours
it's you know it's it's it's incredibly
frustrating and because all of the
speakers are contractually obligated to
put a meme up you know the this is this
is kind of how I feel it's like it's
very uncomfortable my favorite movie
hooks
focus it's very uncomfortable and you
know it's it's it's it's not something
that's great for your design okay so
let's say that you've got a long running
test this is sort of the hello world of
long running tasks you've got your
you've got your your your text input
which is who are we gonna say hello -
hello - today an action button that when
we click it will will run the thing and
then in the text output we're gonna put
hello - we're gonna say hello - ever
whoever we want all right so we've got a
reactive value and that value is being
rendered into the result and then when
we hit run we got a nice little progress
bar here which is going to close and
then we're doing our long-running task
down here we're updating our progress
bar and in the end we put our salutation
salutation in there right so very simple
and it's and it's sort of like how you
would go about it at you know just going
ahead and like naively writing your code
so you go ahead and run this hello world
you know I don't care I don't care about
the world I only care about you guys so
so we want to say hello to you guys so
we've got a nice little progress bar
here I understand how long it's going to
take of course there are some there are
some major issues with with doing that
this sort of naive way and and and the
good thing is users show in progress I
get insight into the computation the bad
thing is the entire the entire server's
blocked nobody can do anything else
while that while while we're figuring
out how to say hello to whoever we want
to say hello to and no other output
values in the user interface if there
were multiple output things would be
updated while this computation is
running also not on here the user can't
cancel that operation
I decide oh these parameters I don't
want to do a hundred thousand bootstraps
because that's going to take ten years I
want to lower it to to a hundred there's
no way to to cancel that operation the
solution which Joe presented it at the
last our studio conference is to utilize
asynchronous computation to kick that
long-running task out to a separate
process and then return the values back
so here's an implementation of hello
world with a sink basically everything's
the same except for now we're kicking
out using the future package our
long-running computation is happening
outside and then we get the result of
that computation and then it kicks back
to our local and assigns that to our
reactive value okay so this is good
you'll notice that we assigned to a
temporary value here the value of our
input and we have to do that because the
the process that you kick off as a child
can have no calm no interaction doesn't
have access to the reactive context it's
an entirely separate process and these
two can't talk to each other and so you
need to assign that to a temporary value
which is then shipped off to that to
that process to for for utilization okay
so then we can go ahead and just run
that so with async
so if async now we're hit run oh god how
long is this gonna take I don't know
because we don't have a progress bar
anymore and the reason why we don't have
a progress bar is because we don't have
access to our reactive context there's
no communication that can happen and so
we finally get our hello world back but
we've had to drop that progress bar
okay so the good thing is the server's
not blocked and actually the way that we
coded it up output values can be updated
while that computation is running the
bad is we've lost all visibility into
the computation it doesn't know about
the server the server doesn't know about
it
the only time making interacts after the
computation is done so that's where the
IPC package comes along IPC is a package
that's devoted to its devoted to
providing mechanism for to communicate
back and forth between processes and to
ship computations and expressions
between these copy threads for for
execution now here's just a simple a
simple code here we create a queue now
these messaging queues can be backed by
some sort of external database that both
of the processes have access to by
default that is done via via temporary
files using the the txt cue package but
other backings are available for
instance Redis is also is also an
implemented option now each queue has a
consumer that contains methods for
processing things from the queue and a
producer to fire off messages to the
queue so here we have future we're going
to create a future it's going to just
basically run forever periodically
having the consumer run consume and then
in our main thread we're gonna sell the
producer to fire off a message to
evaluate the expression stop stop that
child in the in the in the future
so when that consume is called after and
it reads the message it will process it
and execute the expression stop stop
that child and then the future will
throw an error and the future will stop
okay so important methods and the
consumer side you've got consume this
will process all of the messages on the
key
and it will evaluate it
those those messages in the environment
which you provide it by default that's
the environment in which it was called
start is similar except it just runs
consume every periodically as long as
the as long as our is idle also we have
the the queue comes shipped with with
with the ability to handle a couple of
different types of messages but you can
also add your own custom handlers to
handle particular signals and messages
that you want to send on the producer
side you fire off signals using the
fired method and there's a couple of
special ones that are useful you can
fire
eval will will signal for to evaluate an
expression fire call will signal to
evaluate a to call a function with
arguments dot dot or a fire do call will
fire the function called name with
parameters list per am so basically you
can have your own custom handlers but
you can do almost because evaluation and
and calls are so flexible you can
basically do any sort of computational
message that you want to send via fire
call fire eval or fire call okay so
here's here's an example before we saw
sending a message from from the parent
to the future here we're going to send
from the future to the child so we
create a queue and then in the future
we're going to fire an eval which is
going to print index and then what we're
going to do is over here so when you
fire eval it will substitute the values
in the second argument into the
expression so we're going to substitute
I in for index here and so I is going
from one to a hundred so this will
basically count from one to a hundred
and it will say hey go print this out
and here in the in the parent thread and
so that's pretty easy
so you can just rub that and so
basically while our is idle in the in
the thread it will just keep on printing
out these numbers till it gets to gets
to a hundred and that's all coming from
the other process okay so we talk bat
fight finally we're getting back to
shiny we've got some special stuff in in
in this package specifically for shiny
because that's really the major use case
that we're trying to target shiny queue
creates a queue with a few extras
specifically for shiny applications it
also does cleanup of the queue and
temporary files and everything you know
on session ends so you don't have to
worry about any of that stuff it's also
got a couple of methods fire notify and
fire assigned reactive for creating
notifications or assigning values to
reactive values specifically and also
we've got two really important classes
async progress is a drop-in replacement
for four shinies progress class that
will allow you to do progress bars in
your in your long-running task async
interrupter is another one that's
important for Senate it's a class for
sending interrupt signals so you just
call the interrupt method in let's say
your your shiny application and then
periodically with in the future you call
exec interrupts and it will check that
for any interrupts that have been
signaled and we'll throw an error okay
so we can take a look at two of those in
practice in our example application so
here's a very similar application so
we've just got a run and a cancel button
and some output so here we're creating a
new interrupter and then when we hit the
Run button we're going to create a new
progress bar
and now we've kicked off into our future
and the progress we're gonna increment
the progress within our future and we're
going to check for any interrupts and
we'll throw an error if we if we hit one
and then over here
if the cancel buttons hit then we signal
in interrupts and so yeah we can see
this working so we're doing a complex
analysis hey this is great
I understand how long this is going to
take I get out a very insightful result
which is fantastic and this is
cancelable so I can use or interrupt it
and basically this gives gives you the
ability to have you know a bunch of
different parameters the user can try it
they can say oh no I should have done a
thousand bootstraps not ten thousand I
can I can customize it so that'll take a
reasonable amount of time according to
my own definition how much time do I
have left five and a half minutes so I
can show you an another one that's kind
of fun so we're all familiar with the
Old Faithful geyser example that that
shiny has and it's just an it's just a
it's a simple application it allows you
to create a histogram and change the the
number of bins now what I've added to
this is a little bit of kaleidoscope
action so when when we change it we're
gonna kick off a future well first of
all we create a new shiny queue and we
start execution of the consumer and we
have a color variable that we're gonna
change in that future and here we're
gonna cycle through the rainbow and so
every every second we're gonna change
the color of our of our histogram to it
to a different color and this is going
to happen regardless of us changing
around our
the actual slider value okay so if you
don't remember what it looks like looks
like this it's a nice little thing so
we're cycling through that's fine but
while we're cycling through while we're
doing something we can change this this
slider here and it will keep cycling
through so I know this is this is a bit
of a toy but it shows you that you can
start to make your shiny apps do
multiple things at the same time and
have multiple different interactive
components that are all dynamically
occurring together and that's what the
power of that sort of communication
framework the ability to ship executions
between the different processes that you
have running allows you to do so that is
all I have I'm interested in any
questions
[Applause]
and a question about the like the
producer and consumers is it like
bi-directional zip built-up producers
and consumers or does communication flow
in one direction yeah so anyone can call
it the so you think the object the cue
object can is sort of like a wrapper it
contains both a consumer and a producer
object so you can call any of the
consumer as you can call any of the
producer producer methods have you seen
how this scales by a number of users and
what's the overhead on calling the cue
at reading the cueing function so the
overhead is writing and reading the
message to file so you know that's
pretty pretty quick there was a little
bit of it overhead but we we fixed that
issue when there were very large
messages but especially if you're doing
smaller messages the overhead is is very
minimal and you can also change the
backing to a different faster connection
if you wanted to
you
[Music]